Let's say we don't know how the song might impact engagement. It could make
students less engaged, or make them more engaged. Therefor, we're going to put
here, muse sub song. because the song is the intervention. We're going to try
to test if this parameter will be significantly different from what you've
already found. Our next step is to set a criteria for making a decision. Where
our decision will be to either reject or fail to reject the noll. We have to
choose our alpha level, the alpha level we'll generally use is .05, which means
that for a two tailed test, we have 2.5% or .025 and a porportion of .025 on
the left tail. Then we'll find the z-critical values. And finally, we'll find
the z-score of the sample mean, and see if it falls in the critical region.
Based on that, we'll decide whether to reject or fail to reject the null
hypothesis. That's an overview of everything you were going to do in this
lesson. Before we get cracking, let's make sure you understand what it means to
reject the null. Select the appropriate word in each sentence, so that they all
describe what it means to reject the null. One point of clarification, when
figuring out this second one, just ignore negatives. Let's say the z-critical
value is positive, then how big should be the z-score of the sample mean to
reject the null?